[Music]
my icon my legend Meryl Streep Meryl
Streep you guys real I tell anyone in my
life like Meryl Streep is joining us
it's you know it's incredible and now
we're finally getting our first look at
the icon in action on Thursday Nicole
Kidman instagrammed the first onset shot
of Meryl from big little lies season 2
along with the caption first day on the
set with Meryl and my darling boy
she plays my mother-in-law Perry's
father and with that relation according
to HBO Meryl character
Mary Louise right arrives in Monterrey
searching for answers about her son
Harry rice death are you dead we arrived
at for how this casting dream came to be
race and I would just she would be so
amazing in the role we didn't think we
would get her it was written for her I
mean wanted her and her support of us as
women we greatly appreciate it and while
no premiere date has been set it sounds
like we're in forget another
drama-filled season I think it's gonna
be just as good and exciting and and
deep and that's the first one
[Music]
[Applause]